we got breaking news Katie Hobbs has won
Arizona reports decision desk that they
have flipped the Republican state
Democrat as of 8 50 PM with 98 reporting
Carrie Lake was still down and unable to
win there were not enough remaining
votes so uh they're calling it what do
you think Carrie is going to do I don't
think she's going to take this line down
she better not uh I think she's gonna
file some lawsuits they they absolutely
should she has standing here and she has
to move very very quickly on this one uh
look if the people of Arizona legally
respectfully voted for Katie Hobbs uh so
be it so be it but in today's day and
age with the way this country is going
uh Carey Lake absolutely should not and
in order to solve the problem of 2020
and now 2022 with ballot harvesting and
Universal mail-in voting the long lines
the adjudication the broken machines you
need standing and that standing just
happened right now Kerry Lake negatively
impacted by fire lawsuits now
it's entirely possible the State of
Arizona is gonna have judges who just
say no thank you have a nice day as they
did in 2020 but this is the way the way
it works so now now Begins the legal
battle
which I think should happen and I think
there's one there's two things to say
about Arizona one universal mail-in
voting as I've I've described Ad nauseam
mom says come on kids we're going out to
dinner her 18 19 year old kids will live
at home because the economy's in the
gutter and then she does before we got
to dinner fill out your ballots and
those kids go Mom I don't care about
this and just just fill it out and we'll
go to Olive Garden unlimited breadsticks
so they do that greatly helps Democrats
Republicans don't have that same ballot
harvesting game the bigger issue
with Democrats doing that and then
Republicans going in on Election Day and
this is partly Trump's fault the
machines were busted many of the
machines weren't working videos popping
up of them rejecting bouts ballots were
the the ink wasn't wasn't properly laid
so the machine was having trouble
scanning it then they had to put him in
and adjudicated some people were leaving
because the lines were too long
disenfranchising Republican voters and
probably I would argue enough that is a
problem that must be adjudicated it must
be solved in the courts uh otherwise
this problem will never be solved if
there's one thing Kerry Lake can do you
know even if she doesn't become governor
she can stop the broken process so the
next time around this doesn't happen I
need to confirm Katie Hobbs is in charge
of the election in Arizona yes and she
did not recuse herself obviously and
neither did Brian camp in 2018. this is
like well a huge deal that someone is in
charge of an election they won and it
was in 2018 with Brian Kemp and he's the
Republican same thing he was the uh he
was in charge of the elections the
Democrats cried foul he ended up winning
and they claimed he disenfranchised
voters to win I'm sorry to cut you off
no no and Stacy Abrams then spent four
years screaming that she was basically
the governor what's also what's also
interesting about about Hobbes is that
Hobbes refused to debate Carrie like so
when you talk about how fetterman you
know had obviously has some level of
brain damage or whatever the stroke did
him on top of all the bad ideas and
everything else so Democrats can put up
candidates that barely can speak
fetterman and Biden and they can also
now put up candidates who literally will
not debate the other person this is a
huge problem it's it's a it's a function
problem but it's it's a problem it's
like
how you remember that but was it about a
month ago when she said uh well you know
we're busy with fundraisers so I don't
think I'm gonna have time for a debate
you know well then that seems
disqualifying I I I I think
you know I was talking about this the
day after the election I wake up and I
see all these Republicans like how could
this have happened is this Trump's fault
and you know uh just I'm like I don't
understand why is everybody so mad the
Republicans won like they they the
projections were 224 in the house now
it's 219. maybe in a week I'll be like
well I guess they didn't win because
more ballots came in and they cured them
or whatever I don't know yeah they're
saying Lauren bobert might lose now but
um as long as the Republicans take the
house that's it by one vote they changed
the speaker Pelosi's fired and then they
can start subpoenas and and all that
stuff and uh fingers crossed I think
they're projecting like 97 90 chance
that's what's going to happen now at
this point and I'm like what more could
Republicans have wanted if he got the
Senate then you get random yeah you get
Rand Paul on the on the health committee
you can ask about you questions he's
already done that so they're not going
to pass laws there's no veto proof
majority Biden wouldn't allow it I think
there's there's two uh Silver Linings
here with fetterman winning you're not
now going to have endless memes about
how insane the Democrats are for
electing this guy they're going to try
and keep him out of the press
to a great degree and also it sort of
absolves Republicans of any
responsibility for the downturn that
happens so as bad as it's been over the
past couple of years and it's not going
to improve already they're talking about
the economy is expected to get worse
there's going to be a major economic
crisis next year the Republicans can be
like hey y'all vote a Democrat we barely
got the majority by one by plus one
seats so you know don't look at us 2024
There's an opportunity if they fix the
universal mail right that's the thing
that's what I was gonna say it still
comes down to that because things are
pretty shitty now you know we're in a
recession although they don't call they
change the definition of recession so it
doesn't quite count the supply chain
stuff just try to order something from
Crate and Barrel see how long it takes
try to buy a window right like literally
anything
um so there are a million things on top
of the fact does anyone in this room not
think that Joe Biden is mentally
compromised or anyone watching this is
you know you said you didn't want to get
booted off YouTube tonight it'd be very
nice yeah compromise but the point is
all know there's something wrong with
the president we all know that none of
this is working as I said that there's
just lies everywhere and we just keep
going with it well we don't well no
right the problem is the male info
machine or whatever so so when when did
you realize Joe Biden was not all with
it was it uh battle Cafe next now recent
Trinity pressure or was it um
you know pronunciations are pretty solid
on those things because you know I work
easy words just you know intentionally
should have done a shop at a pressure I
sat and listened to that to try and
really get oh and now he's got rela land
yeah you saw that one right that was
just a couple days ago yeah rule of the
land he's trying to say perhaps I'm not
here to translate Biden true
International he's got two words America
is back like everything made in America
I got two words well that's what it was
made in America this matters you hear
them say that a lot and this matters
we just witnessed I I don't see
Republicans winning ever again I I
talked about this specifically in my
earlier video today now you could
criticize Donald Trump since his main
issue for this midterm was talking about
the 2020 election you could criticize
them from doing fundraisers for Masters
and and receiving 99 out of a hundred
dollars and giving only one dollar to
Masters that was uh uh you know that was
that was outpaid for by his opponent 80
million dollars to 12 million dollars
you could criticize them on that but
when you have the ballot harvesting when
you have the mail-in ballots
additionally when you have big Tech
censorship when you have yellow bellies
and neoconservatives in the Republican
party I don't see them winning ever
again in the near future what else could
help them win they have no institutional
power to change any of this they won't
change anything and even if they did I
wouldn't even have any uh you know
optimism that they would so I think
you're making my earlier argument which
is sort of you strengthen the red States
and you bring in all the good people
from the blue States
yeah you let the blue States crumble
under the weight of Their Own [ __ ]
and you strengthen you bring all of the
productive people you bring all of the
productive companies you hire based on
skilled instead of equity you do all of
it right and then you save certain
places and then
you just kind of go man it was beautiful
in the 80s and the 90s but we we
couldn't hold on to it that's a good
argument because even like 20 brilliant
people can completely transform a state
of course like you don't even need 20 of
them yeah look what's happening in Miami
right now they took all of the
worthwhile Talent from Silicon Valley
they didn't take all the social justice
Warriors they took the main people from
Silicon Valley they brought them into
Miami Suarez is doing an incredible job
he literally I mean it was the Tweet
right his tweet was how can I help and
he basically brought an entire industry
there in Miami is exploding as opposed
to imploding which is what's happening
well we chose we chose West Virginia
and we've actually uh we've moved
employees to come out to the area we're
expanding the operation we're starting a
couple new businesses and we're going to
continue to expand our West Virginia
operation the cities here are very small
but it's surrounded by uh it's it's it's
really interesting we're only a couple
we're three hours from Pittsburgh we're
three hours from Philadelphia we're an
hour from DC an hour from Baltimore
we're two and a half hours from Richmond
we have all these major Urban centers
all around us but we're in a red state
with a lot more freedom it's not perfect
West Virginia's got issues but we're
gonna fix them we're gonna fix them
there's a big opportunity here in the
land being cheap there's airports nearby
they have infrastructure Central West
Virginia is another story but I think we
can do a lot of good here and and um I
came down here because you know a friend
recommended coming out coming down here
and now I see great opportunity and uh I
looked I've been looking at the local uh
representatives and the the
Congressional reps and they're based you
know they're like Ron Paul type
politicians and I'm like this is a good
opportunity
I look at Florida and it's incredible
but that weather man
you're talking about the weather is
freaking awesome I live in Miami I was
there all summer yes it's humid it is
and they have a statue to the guys
yes there's a thing called an air
conditioner and it conditions the air
respect your inside respect to that guy
no brilliant Adventure we're gonna see
it you guys are running from being here
right now it's like 20 degrees outside
and you got AC going on in here right
now so yeah that was not my fault so
someone turned the AC on I have no idea
why it's 40 degrees Tim's gonna go
through a transformation where he
removes the beanie and goes to Florida I
lived in Miami oh wait a minute were you
wearing a bikini issue with you that's
what this is seven degrees oh yeah I
lived in Miami yeah and the issue is
when there's two months out of the year
you can skate and it's January and
February I'm telling you I just was in
Florida this morning in Miami it was
about 72 abs absolutely beautiful the
iguanas okay November December January
this is a beanie issue with you it is
you don't want to be the guy in the
sweaty beanie oh there's the sweaty
beanie that's not true because I'm
always the sweaty beanie guy no but
you're obviously sweating a lot less
here you don't want to be August sweaty
beanie Tim and people have you
experienced Chicago summer my friend uh
Chicago in the summer it is absolutely
not the issue because I actually use the
beanies as sweat rags and I strain them
out as I'm skating and I'm not I'm not
exaggerating anybody who watches me
skate knows that it's it's black then
because it's you always wear black and
you feel like you'd be very out of place
there it's very hip yeah if you watch
the castle
you'd see me wearing a light blue helmet
and a white shirt while I'm skating oh
so it is gonna happen you're telling me
because I'm no no no no you've got a
sweat rag on your head you've got your
neon colored clothes it always looks
slow when you're already transformation
up close getting ready no uh Florida is
expensive that's that's the real issue
it is expensive they have to work on
that we looked at uh I I looked at
Florida and it's expensive and West
Virginia was way more land way cheaper
way more freedom we can shoot guns yeah
Florida's definitely got places you can
do it you could go down to Homestead
that's where that's where I lived yeah
oh is that right I mean there's land and
there's guns
awesome just north of uh Homestead and
um what was the street number I don't
know it's the Redlands yeah Redlands
yeah yeah I lived over there for a year
we had a five acre property we had
chickens and it was it was it's
beautiful during the thunderstorms man
it's really really amazing the
thunderstorms roll in five times a week
yeah and then we're just sitting
watching the trees so now you're telling
me how great the weather you did here
Temple we had so many coconuts it was
insane how many coconuts we had we had
too many coconuts so you have coconuts
you have the storms that you're happy
about you know I'll tell you the weather
is not really that relevant compared to
the good laws especially you know I
talked to everybody here I said if if
Rhonda Santos really gets this law
passed on social media protections we
relocate an instant yeah
listen I I don't want to speak out of
turn here I just know they're working on
a million things they're working on ESG
stuff like they are doing everything
we're asking so for all of these people
out there as I tweeted this morning if
you think that Ron DeSantis is part of
the machine and he is just one of the
generic ones and he's just a Romney or
something like that it's like man he's
done everything you've asked he's
crushing in elections like there will
never be somebody good enough for you if
that's your take on it that's the crazy
thing you tweeted something I thought
was really good you said Rhonda Santos
is doing everything we're asking for and
he's winning and people are accusing him
like this is yeah this proves that he's
bad right because you because people
have been so beaten into submission that
when the good thing happens they think
it it must be transitory something like
that but it doesn't have to be it
doesn't have to be if we then go and
start building the proper institutions
which is exactly what he did he cleaned
up voting knowing that he's not going to
be around forever I'm still skeptical of
DeSantis especially with him not being
able to pass constitutional carry in in
Florida but at the same time well they
just got a super majority now which if
he does I mean all out respects when he
if he does push this through uh but he
does go against the trans agenda he
shipped illegal migrants to to Martha's
Vineyard he's fighting fiercely against
the ESG social credit score and
how about you how can you call him
establishment no it's just crazy and
then and then Florida was one of the few
states that survived the whole weight of
all the lockdowns of all the
restrictions they were the number one
state that was attacked for allegedly
killing people by allowing them to be
free and they stood up against it and he
stood up against fauci more than AOC
went to vacation in Florida with no mask
you gotta change his wardrobe it's the
suit makes people think he's
establishment being in a hot Florida sun
in a suit do you think it's maybe that a
certain set of people just use the
phrase establishment to mean just sort
of anything that's like somewhat normal
you know he's got he's got people like
Ken Griffin yeah you know who's come out
supporting him and Ken Griffin was the
money guy Citadel guy establishment
funding but my attitude is I mean who
who did Trump have him funding like
exactly but my answer is this look just
because someone when they went after I
think it was Rubio they said you're
getting money from the NRA they own you
and he says yeah he's like I don't get
take get money from them because I do
things for them I get money from them
because I'm doing things already and
they want those things to happen yeah
that's the thing DeSantis is winning I
think these people are like well it's
Cults Communists critical race Theory or
DeSantis I'll take DeSantis yeah look
it's very obvious that I was in I did a
show with DeSantis in Orlando it was the
last show on my book tour in Orlando so
we went to Disney country and everybody
there everybody there was psyched to see
the guy excited we had people in the
meet and greet coming up to me after
that were Disney employees that could
potentially lose their job if he cuts
you know if he gets rid of these tax
benefits and everything and they were
coming up to us telling how uh telling
him how appreciative they were so
everyone has moved on this stuff nobody
wants this everyone knows that this woke
nonsense in schools and talks second
grade teachers talking to kids about sex
or gender identity or call imagine you
had a kid and you found out that the
teacher the third grade teacher male
teacher was talking to your daughter
secretly about sex and calling her a
boys name or vice versa any which way
you want to play that like we all know
it's wrong but again we just need more
adults to be like hey we're here we
forgot yeah we were supposed to be with
a sick sexual fantasy for a teacher to
do that to a kid Twisted thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time